[Music]
do
we're so excited to have you here at the
table
if you're new welcome we're so excited
to have you if you're joining us online
we're really excited that you're tuning
in tonight
we have one quick announcement and that
is for october 31st which falls on a
sunday this year and so we are going to
be doing instead of our regular service
we'll be meeting here but it will be for
a trunk or treat um the table will be
providing food and games and drinks if
you would like you can sign up in the
back to decorate your trunk and give
kids candy it'll be a lot of fun and we
hope that you guys can join us
i'm going to go ahead and pray and then
we'll get into the worship
lord thank you so much for this evening
we're so excited to be in your presence
thank you for this week and i just pray
that we can
put everything off that we are thinking
about our grocery list our to-do list
and really focus on you this evening
thank you for your love
and your power
and please be with us as we learn more
about you this evening
we love you lord your son's amazing
incredible name amen
amen thank you it's so good to see a new
face up in front of everybody love that
thanks mariah
um
well as we get started tonight i was
just going to tell you guys about a
quick conversation i had in kind of the
context of this first song that we're
doing there's some lines in the song
that can seem a little uh
creepy maybe
[Laughter]
where it kind of seems like god is that
person that's just sitting there
watching your every move and telling you
know your mistakes and
um
anyways i was
tucking my little girl into bed the
other day and
and anyway they were asking like what uh
so who made who made god how did how did
god come and i was just like i
this is
a hard question okay
how did god come and so anyways we got
into this conversation about how
i believe god is just this source that
always was and always is and it's ever
present with us just that ever present
love of god it's in the breasts that we
take it's in the love that we feel in
our family god is every time there's
love there's god and when there's not
love we look for god for him to come you
know for him to make things right we we
invite him into those moments like god
is that presence and so anyways i just
wanted to share that with you this
little conversation i had with my kids
but i also feel like sometimes i have to
reframe and reorient my mind when i'm
singing a worship song that can
sometimes feel like am i looking this at
this through my old lens of uh kind of
the
rulemaker god who's waiting for us to
screw up or am i looking at it through a
lens of love as brett would say a
hermeneutic of love did i say the word
right herman eunick
so anyways i hope that that's how we're
approaching this um i invite you into
that approach if you came from old
school
teachings like i did some of them that
need to be reframed reshifted
let's connect with that ever present
love of god that's there
all right
let's get started one two
three
four
[Music]
yeah you guys can stand up
is there a place that we can go
where you cannot find us
you're there when we fall
[Music]
you're there when we rise
nothing is hidden from your face
we
take
[Music]
together
nothing on
earth above or below
[Music]
you came to us
made us your own
[Music]
you have redeemed us
is
[Music]
we are yours
love has forever us it's all around us
holding us and we will sing because your
love has found us even in the dark
[Music]
set us free
we will sing because your love has found
us even
[Music]
set us free
we are yours forever
[Music]
your love has found us even in the
darkest nights will sing because your
love has set us
free we will sing because your love has
found us even in the darkest nights
we'll sing because your love has set us
free
[Music]
let the king of my heart
be the mountain where i run
the fountain
[Music]
let the king help my heart
be the shadow where i hide
the ransom for my life oh he is
[Music]
you are good
you're good
[Music]
the king of my heart be the wind inside
my sails
the anchor in the waves oh he is my song
let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins
the echo of my days
oh he
you is good
you're good
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're never gonna let you're never
gonna let me down
[Music]
you're never gonna let me down
you're never gonna let
[Music]
you are good
oh
you're good
[Music]
you're never gonna let me down
you're good
[Music]
you are good
you're good
[Music]
god thank you for your goodness
thank you for being an ever-present
source of love in our life thank you for
being the light
the hope
the kindness the forgiveness
we're going to go into our prayers of
the people
and this is a part in our service where
we want to shoulder each other's burdens
and the things that are on our hearts
and if you're online joining us feel
free to comment in our sections and we
will be reading those out loud in our
service so that we can shoulder
this together
and if there are red words on the screen
if you guys could read those with me
that would be great and just feel free
and in the space during the prayer to
share a name or a situation that's on
your heart tonight and we will lift
those up before god together
[Music]
i'm getting i'm getting a waiting signal
from the back so just one second all
right
for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan for the
injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so now we lift these
names and situations up to you
karen miner's dad
from online josie's mom
nancy's chemo treatments
delaine brock
karen statteritcher
[Music]
nikki and roy
the kunsman family
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope peace and a
deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
all the poor and powerless
and all the things
know that you're
holy
and know that you're
[Music]
it's all the hearts through our content
know that you are holy
[Music]
we
will cry
[Music]
we
will cry
[Music]
shout
go on and tell it to
[Music]
that he is
out
go on and scream it from the mountain
go on and tell it
that he is
[Music]
[Applause]
go on and tell it to the masses
[Music]
that he is
cry
[Music]
is
go on and tell it
that he is
[Music]
go on and scream it from the mountains
go on and tell it to the masses
that he is
[Music]
jesus thank you that everyone's welcome
that you've provided room for all people
and all races
and all economic levels and all stories
and all past and all genders
jesus thank you that you are a god
of complete total love and invitation to
us god
would your presence just rest here with
us
as we connect
as we listen
as we absorb new thoughts and ideas and
information god
would we sense your presence
of welcome and invitation in our lives
god would we be able to respond to it
thank you for who you are
thank you for being a god who wants to
be with us
it's in your name i pray
amen
if you guys want to turn and say hello
to someone around you brett is going to
go on get us started with the message
good evening everyone
grace and peace
it's so good to be with you so so good
and um i want to welcome all of you but
that of course includes
those joining us online
we love you lots
and as well as anyone uh who's
new i think i don't see any new faces
here but perhaps online so welcome yeah
so glad that you're a part of us here at
the table um
so the title of my message tonight uh is
how not to take communion
how not to take communion it's a strange
title um
but i think our text will make it kind
of clear what's going on as we as we get
into this so our text is going to be
first corinthians chapter 11. if you've
got your bibles you can flip there or
follow along on the screen
as you'll pretty quickly be able to tell
the apostle paul who is the really one
of the first great missionaries church
planters theologians
if you've ever read his letters in the
new testament you know from time to time
he gets real riled up
downright angry and
[Music]
it's i would say this is definitely one
of the moments where it's um well well
warranted so again we'll kind of get
into it so all right we'll start in
verse 17 of chapter 11.
in the following directives i have no
praise for you
you can tell he's he's a real charmer
for your meetings do more harm than good
in the first place i hear that when you
come together as a church there are
divisions among you and to some extent i
believe it uh keep in mind you know
paul's kind of traveling around so he's
not like a local pastor who's there week
and week out he's a church planter so he
kind of plants a church and he like
moves on um so he's all over the place
so he's you know he's getting wind he's
hearing of what's going on at this
church and of course he has to take
everything with a grain of salt but
that's why he says to some extent i
totally believe it um
now speaking of these divisions just
give you a little bit of a background
this will be a quick footnote um so in
chapter one of this same book first
corinthians
he starts off by talking about how there
were um
basically people kind of had their like
favorite preachers
slash kind of celebrity christians
um so they were saying things like well
i'm really a follower of paul and
another was like well i'm really just a
huge fan of peter and still another was
like well i i just love apollo's
preaching um and so they had these they
were latching onto these kind of leaders
and what was happening was of course
christ was kind of getting pushed to the
margins of their gatherings as they all
probably kind of bickered about who's
their favorite celebrity preacher we
actually know um for example somewhere i
think it's in the book of acts it talks
about how apollos really was like a
great speaker like he was really good at
presenting paul on the other hand was a
better letter writer he wasn't some
people said he wasn't so good in like
the pulpit so you can kind of see where
probably all the like theologian people
who want to read that they're like i'm a
follower of paul you know and then
someone who just likes a good message
they're like i have a pilot so you can
see where this these divisions started
kind of finding their way into the
church and so paul he he just i mean
he's had none or
he's had enough of this so he's actually
a really clever way he um kind of starts
shutting this down in his letter because
again he has to write to try to shut it
down he can't be there so in chapter one
he says um did uh
did paul
die on the cross for
you that's so good
he's a did uh were you baptized in the
name of peter
he says no
no no this it was the lord jesus
who died across your sins it was lord
jesus whose name you were baptized into
like this is who this is about like
let's not get sidetracked so there's
these are kind of the echoes of the
divisions that he's referring to as
you'll see though as we get into this it
gets the divisions actually went even
deeper than that though everyone having
their um favorite you know celebrity
preachers also you know thankfully we've
totally outgrown this in the modern
church you know no more celebrity
preachers
for us
uh okay i'm not gonna get into that i
won't all right verse 19.
no doubt there have to be differences
among you to show which of you have
god's approval
again a sort of i don't see passive
aggressive i'm not sure what he's
getting at here verse 20 so then
when you come together it is not the
lord's supper you eat
for when you are eating
some of you go ahead with your own
private suppers as a result one person
remains hungry and another gets drunk
don't you have homes to eat and drink in
or do you despise the church of god by
humiliating those who have nothing this
will be a key line um for interpretation
later
what shall i say to you shall i praise
you
certainly not in this matter
can you can you feel the
some of the tension um
all right so what's what's going on in
this background like what's the
background here in this text so um the
early church had a practice of combining
what they called uh a love feast
and the taking of the lord's supper so
the love feast was basically like we
would probably call it like a church
potluck or meal
um and their idea was you know we often
think of communion as a very kind of
somewhat gloomy serious you know thing
and that was true like you'll see later
he talks about examining yourself and
things like that um so that kind of has
its place but it wasn't quite the feel
of the early church when they do
communion it was really kind of the
celebrations they would like have church
have a big meal and then they would
segue into um
you know into communion um however
the the little kind of trick was so keep
in mind this was you know like a real
church at a particular time in a
particular place in the world so 2000
years ago they're in the province of
corinth and that city had a certain
culture and as was true in a lot of the
ancient world
um
there was a certain protocol
for how you ate food
things like uh who you ate the food with
where you sat at the meal spoke volumes
we kind of even have some of that today
you know like you go to the birthday
party of the friend and whoever's
sitting like right next to the friend
you know they're like really good
friends you know and someone who's like
way down the end especially it's like
arranged seating you know and you're
kind of way down there you you kind of
it speaks to the relationship right
so
imagine though if every meal was kind of
like that like very um thought through
about who you sat with where you sat who
ate first who ate last um even down to
what type of food got served to who
so you had you know the fancy food
the high quality stuff that even um you
saw the reference about getting drunk so
they would like have wine
at these love feasts
and i mean it's possible even that the
wine like there was like the good stuff
and then like the trader joe's one
dollar bottle
which i'm not i'm not too good for that
i like that cheap one all right so so
you've got these right this is kind of
the thing going on um
so also keep in mind a little background
when you um
there's reference here to those who have
nothing so you know in the ancient world
like
to be poor there really wasn't a welfare
system or state or anything so you know
to be poor was i mean it meant skipping
meals
i just over the summer i read nelson
mandela's amazing
his autobiography i mean it's incredible
and if you've read that's like
man it's incredible but
it was interesting to hear him talk
about being poor growing up in south
africa and how for him
just like honestly in corinth that meant
skipping meals like and he had some
education this was when he was just
trying to start his law practice there
in south africa
and he did not have enough food to eat
three meals a day sometimes he couldn't
even eat certain days so he would like
choose like monday skip tuesday skip
wednesday thursday skip friday and like
he just couldn't afford it he didn't
have the money um
now i mean no just we actually did a
message a few years ago on on hunger and
that's still there's still kind of an
issue with this in the united states um
though with food banks and things like
that
boy hopefully that's really been
lessened you know um but but just keep
in mind that's not the case in like
corinth this was a very stratified
society you had the upper class you had
the lower classes and to be on that low
rung of the society it it was rough i
mean it's rough today terrible to live
in poverty but in corinth 2000 years ago
like you hunger was a real thing
so okay so so what's going on well you
probably already started connecting the
dots right so basically what you had
were these wealthy kind of upper class
i haven't missed a meal in a year
corinthian christians
who were
prioritizing themselves
at the at the feast whose name was love
can you see the irony like in this it's
the love here we go
um they they were um
they were prioritizing themselves
again think of it at the very meal that
was the build-up to communion like that
was the whole point was the kind of
segue from the meal into communion this
moment where we were going to they were
going to worship the jesus who gave of
himself
the very one who served the jesus who
didn't look to his own interests but to
the interests of others at that meal
where they remembered the jesus who said
the first shall be last and the last
shall be
first
like at that meal
the rich
the upper class folks were elbowing
their way
to the front of
the line
so in effect what you had were the
people who hadn't skipped meals that
week were now getting the best seat the
best food
first place and everything and those who
and actually mentions even to the point
of getting completely wasted like
they're having a party they're just
living it up
while meanwhile you had those who went
hungry all week coming to this feast
whose name is love and leaving
like basically picking through the
crumbs the leftovers
and so
this is why paul is so
hacked off i mean he's he's livid
about this
um so this gets me to thinking like what
does what does this mean for us what can
we learn i want to give you um a few
lessons tonight
i'll call it just three lessons from
this this passage that i think apply uh
to us in our own day so here's the first
one the church must take its cues from
christ
not the surrounding culture
like i know this is basic like oh of
course christians should follow christ
um you'd think it'd be obvious you know
but here's the thing um culture it just
it saturates us
it just sucks us right in it's sort of
like culture is to us as water is to a
fish
i mean you're just immersed in it this
is why you have a cross-cultural
experience and all of a sudden you
realize oh i've been in a culture this
whole time oh my gosh didn't even think
about that didn't think i had a culture
until i went to someone else's culture
and i realized oh i have a culture and
it's different than their culture right
like this it's just invisible it's so
and so what happens it just it just eats
us up i mean we or for we just to switch
the metaphor we eat it up if we just
take it in it just becomes a part of us
it seeps into every cell of our body
it's just how we are and this is my
what's what's interesting is i'm
imagining
people keep in mind how these letters
came to churches so basically it's not
like everyone had a bible um they had
the old testament not anything in the
new so these letters when you would
write a letter to the churches in this
area of corinth they would then be read
publicly in church like hey everyone
take your seats take your seats we got a
new letter from paul all right let's see
what he has to say and the following
directives i have no praise for you
right like you can imagine and
everyone's sitting there
right so i'm just imagine you're kind of
the upper class corinthian christians
in this like is it hot in here i feel
like it's getting hot um and i'm just i
mean one thing
it's now it's possible they were very
aware of what they were doing it's also
possible that they really weren't
uh in fact i'm imagining them hearing
this it's kind of hitting them and it's
sort of like their eyes are opening
but then as human beings are prone to do
at least if they're anything like me i
would probably be really prone to get
defensive so i have this uh this is my
imaginary
kind of um reaction from upper class
corinthian christians this is how i'm
imagining
their their kind of unchristian response
so here it is well paul
that's just not the way we do things
around here
i've been a corinthian my whole life my
dad was a corinthian my grandpappy even
my great-grandpappy all corinthians and
for as long as i can remember this is
just how our world works yes of course
everyone's equal but
some are more equal than others
animal farm anyone catch their hands
yeah
i've worked hard for my position
i've earned my spot in society
and paul if you think
for one
minute
that i'm going to come to this church
and lay down my dignity and my god-given
rights so that some person with half my
education level
and intelligence
can turn their nose up at me
and saunter their way to the front of
the line that's just not how we do
things around these parts paul
can you kind of hear i mean it's it's
eerie how like we can see it for them
right like oh my gosh that's so classist
and like
and yet um
i mean how much did this seep i mean
just imagine
uh it's not even that long ago i mean i
i can think of there's a couple um you
all know actually they're a part of our
church now but when i first met him it
was roy nikki parker an interracial
couple and they've told me stories of
going to the church i grew up at
and
folks told them many years later that
when they walked through the doors
they had the thought of like well that's
just not right
like i'm gonna be i'll try to be nice to
them but that's just not
that's just not how we you know do
things
uh which will actually get to a little
while around racism and like
and that was i mean i started going to
that church in like 1993
so i mean isn't it remarkable how these
things the culture it just
seeps in
it just seeps and through podcasts and
music and art and
uh well back in the day radio and
television and of course now the
internet just it just seeps and before
you know it like in that little rant i
gave from that um stuck up terrible
corinthian christian like in their mind
they're just you know speaking the truth
sometimes you have to say the hard thing
you know and they don't realize how in
conflict it is with their christian
identity
this is a huge problem it i think we can
see now why in verse 11
paul says uh that your meetings do more
harm than good
isn't that a remarkable statement like i
mean we think what's church
you know so churches get together well
that's a good that's good and yet paul
is saying sometimes churches can get
together and it's a net loss
you can come and sing the songs and the
preacher can preach the word and you
know give you a good exegetical line by
line sermon and it can just the whole
thing can be a
failure
because
we're not actually
following jesus
we're not actually following the christ
we claim to love
and what does that mean what does it
mean to be a christian i'll sum it up
this way to be christian is actually to
lay down my rights and my privileges and
my preferences and my status so that i
can become the servant of all
and this is why you can put the word
church
on the side of your building there you
have it around here pleasant valley
united methodist church there it is
right and anyone can do that you could
just put a church
and yet fail to actually do it
right in the same way as individuals we
can say like jesus
jesus the good lord my devote my life to
christ you know you can do say all the
things
but if we're if we're not living into it
in this way
like it's what are we doing
what are we doing
all right so that's first we've got to
take our cues from christ and we've got
to be very careful of how how is culture
kind of seeping in ways we don't even
realize um second
the church must continually purge itself
of classism racism sexism ageism
and so on and so forth you know all the
isms um again why because it just seeps
and of course paul's dealing with class
right the upper classes often in any
culture i mean my goodness
for as long as humans have been around
we have this class differences
and then there's a tendency to exploit
and take advantage of and so what is
church well if the church is being the
way it's supposed to be it's that place
where people come together and relate
without um
i can't say without seeing that because
honestly we all see it whether we want
to or not but hopefully we're learning
to get over it
and and set aside our prejudices and
our um just ways that we judge
and we're learning to love well
i think of of my friend
he lives now in iowa he grew up in texas
um
but he has some
mental illnesses uh a number of pretty
severe schizophrenia some others um and
so he spent a lot of time in texas he
actually lived in denton for a number of
years
um it was a big deal for him to find a
church
really big um
and he recently over
uh three years ago he moved to iowa
and he lives kind of in a
kind of quasi-institutional
place there it's not really like he's
not in a um like a mental institution
per se it's like a house and a
neighborhood that they've kind of
designated like hey folks can live here
they have someone who lives in there in
the home with folks with some of these
disabilities to make sure you know
they're taking their medication and
showering and you know things like that
but he can still like kind of go around
the neighborhood and whatever so i've
been i try to talk with him every
every week or two um i just call him on
the phone and so it's been three years
now
and um he hasn't yet found a church
and so um i've been like encouraging him
like hey man you just gotta you know go
for it like you can do this
and he's like yeah i know i need you so
i was really excited um last time i
called him last last week
and i was just checking in
and um you know coming back to class
like there's certain things about him
it's pretty clearly you can kind of tell
where folks are on the hierarchy of the
culture
right you kind of know someone pulls up
in their bentley that says something
right
um
and so my friend like it's kind of the
you know there's just certain indicators
like he was homeless for a number of
years so his teeth you know are just
really
not great
um and so there's like certain
indicators that you can kind of tell
like you know i mean his lack of social
skills um
it's just clear he's kind of towards the
bottom of the hierarchy so i you know
talking with him about a church and i
was excited though because he said uh
well because i asked him again like hey
did you have you checked out a church
yeah he said well i went last week i
went
and i was like hey
nice he's like well kind of i was like
what do you mean kind of he said well i
went
and then i just stood outside
but i couldn't go inside and i was like
okay well you know so close like we're
getting better
and i was like well why didn't you go in
and he said honestly i
i don't know man i don't know
but here's the thing i do know
i know
because i've watched him now attend
churches for like seven years
and this is always his criteria like as
when he's visiting churches this is
always the thing he says like he'll go
to one place and he's like oh how'd that
go oh
not great you know and here's the thing
he never talks about like oh the worship
just wasn't quite to my liking or the
preacher you know not exegetical enough
or but like it's never any of that this
is what he always says like they weren't
very nice there
that's what he always says it's always
it's always his word nice
right they weren't very nice there and
then you go to another church and he's
like super excited like oh my gosh i
went to that church those people were so
nice they were so nice like that's
that's his only criteria now what does
he mean
right nice because we kind of look at it
like nice well church isn't just about
being nice we gotta i don't know
whatever critiques of night i get the
word nice isn't maybe the perfect word
what's he getting at he's just talking
about loving
right kind
compassionate like
seeing someone who's different right
different place on the hierarchy and
knowing how to get down and like love
people
right like meeting people where they're
at
my gosh we can't it's like 2 000 years
and we're we're still corinthians
all right we're still just tripping over
we're struggling i don't mean to hammer
like us like we are you all i just you
know i'm talking about the collective we
the church and the times us two heck of
times me
all of us like it's just a struggle
man my prayer um for us may we always be
a church or my friend would be
welcome where he would say those people
are nice
they're nice
i mean maybe that maybe that could be
like the highest thing we ever aspire to
i mean maybe that you know what if
that's it like that's a huge win
if my friend can come in those people
are nice because because what's that
getting at it's back to christ
right this is who we're called to be
like jesus
jesus was nice
especially to
folks like him
of course it's not just class though
when you just keep going on there's
racism
we're struggling but there's there's
just no place in the kingdom of god in
the church in general in at the table no
no space for a um
you know this kind of i'm superior i'm
above
you know because of my racial identity
or they're
they're kind of putting the negative or
there below because right in this
judging of people based on the color of
skin like just
no
just i think this is kind of one of
those topics that i just think is sort
of implied like oh everyone knows i'm
just gonna make it real clear tonight
just so it's kind of implicit in
everything the table does just to make
it explicit like no
we are not going the classism game the
racism game
um
what else of sexism this idea of you
know the certain a certain gender kind
of being like the superior the better
the more qualified it's like no
no no no um another one i thought was
big at least in our kind of context is
age ageism this is interesting like in
the ancient world it was the the older
folks who were like venerated you know
like young people was like shut your
mouth you have no wisdom we don't want
to listen you at all be quiet for like
40 years you know um
now you know it's interesting how things
have reversed
like in our culture there's such a sort
of worship of youth and youthfulness
and um
almost to an obsessive point and that is
totally making its way into churches
where there's this sort of i get and i
do think there's a good thing in terms
of wanting to appreciate young folks and
you know like um yeah like that's
there's a good part of that but the
danger is this weird kind of obsession
with youthfulness and you know every
pastor
uh you know has to fit a certain look
and be a certain way in a certain age
and you know i mean and then even as the
pastor gets older they still kind of
have to pretend like they're still 25
you know and it's kind of like no no
what's but what's going on there well
that's the pressure it's the culture
right and it just seeps in it's sort of
disturbing if you go to a church and
everyone's like a certain class level
and dresses a certain way
um
looks the same
certain age
you know like
everyone wants to be a young church i
think just purely young churches that
should freak us out
like oh gosh just nothing but young
people like how disturbing you know like
no we need so like we need all different
sorts of people here
and okay you guys get it i'm kind of
ranting um
and you know maybe it's not even that
we're like overtly mean to people you
know i think how this often happens we
just kind of ignore
you know just sort of like they're just
not really my person my type of those
those folks whatever the criteria is
in other words
to be christian
i think is sort of the opposite of that
is to render
invisible people visible
i think that's what we're trying to do
in church rendering invisible people
visible to cast no one aside to allow no
one to be
forgotten
oh is it just thinking back to my friend
man he longs to be seen
he does
oh huma we all do don't we human beings
we just long to be seen
heard known
cherished
like
it's simple you know but it's hard to
live out
all right so that's second third the
church must repent of its failures and
turn again
to christ i know that's old-fashioned
language but oh well
i just think it's just the truth like
we've got to repent of the places where
we've messed all this up and be like
yeah let's let's not go down that road
again right like let's turn this is the
picture of repentance i'm going this way
i turn
and i'm going i'm moving towards christ
again
paul kind of addresses this he actually
reminds them about what the lord's
supper is actually all about
um because he says clearly in fact he
even says there's that one line where
he's like um you don't you haven't been
taking the lord's supper like
technically they have right but he's
like nope i don't know what you've been
doing but it's not taking the lord's
effort
so he says this verse 23 here so he's
like here's what it's actually about for
i received
from the lord what i also passed on to
you the lord jesus on the night he was
betrayed he took the bread and when he'd
given thanks he broke it and he said
this is my body which is for you do this
in remembrance of me in the same way
after supper he took the cup saying this
cup is the new covenant of my blood do
this whenever you drink it in
remembrance of me for whenever you eat
this bread and drink this cup you
proclaim the lord's death until he comes
so then whoever eats the bread or drinks
the cup of the lord in an unworthy
manner will be guilty of sinning against
the body and blood of the lord pretty
ominous
everyone ought to examine themselves
before they eat of the bread and drink
from the cup
i think um a lot of confusion has kind
of sprung up around this passage in
particular i think it's probably um from
a not knowing the context right of
everything i just shared with you um
but b i think it's also maybe the king
james here's how the the king
king james uh translation puts it uh
wherefore whosoever
so king james
wherefore whosoever shall eat this bread
and drink this cup of the lord
unworthily
shall be guilty of the body and blood of
the lord um
and i i think that kind of language of
unworthily it kind of pushed us to think
in terms of me individually becoming
i've got to be i've got to be worthy of
the bread and the cup
instead of paul saying in an unworthy
manner
right he's thinking there's maybe still
a place for me individually like some
examination and such but he's really
thinking socially right like in an
unworthy manner
um we we need to
both as individuals and collectively do
some soul searching
as we come to the table to ask this
question what kind of gospel have we
been proclaiming
not with the mouth part of us with with
our bodies with our relating to one
another right that's what it means to
come
and take the bread eat the bread drink
of the cup and do it in a manner that's
worthy of the lord jesus
it's about our relating our
relationships to one another
in other words what kind of gospel have
we been proclaiming has it been
selfishness
in classism
has that been kind of worming its way
into our life either as individuals or
even collectively
um or are we a place where no one feels
invisible
are we the dictators of our homes
or are we the servant
of all
like that's what it's about that's what
it means to partake of the cup um eat of
the bread in a manner that's worthy and
so what i want to do before we take
communion i want to lead us in
a short um
a reading
from this is basically just a prayer of
repentance
um and do we have that can you guys put
that up yeah
cool so what i want to do you guys can
just um read this together um
with me
so
um yeah let's do it that way i think
it'd be a little easier than me reading
a part and you trying to you know all
that back and forth so y'all just read
it with me
holy god
we have not loved as we ought to have
loved
we have allowed the darkness of the
world to blind us to your kingdom ways
of relating
we have demanded our rights privileges
and preferences to the exclusion of
those truly in need
we have adorned ourselves with status
symbols in a desperate attempt to fill
the gaping void within us
we have elbowed our way to the front of
the line
all while proclaiming the christ who
said the first shall be last and the
last shall be first
forgive us
help us to practice the way of
unconditional love
tender heartedness
and compassion
help us to be the church you have called
us to be
amen
so uh each of you should have
a small cup and a little ziploc with
some bread
and if you uh if you need it it should
be on your row or marissa can help you
get some extras
so you can go ahead and take out the
bread
since we'll start there i do want to
mention if you're joining us um online
uh we'd love for you to be able to
participate so if you can go to your
fridge and grab you know a little piece
of bread and maybe a a cup of
grape juice or wine or whatever your
preferences and
just be able to kind of partake
with us and also we practice here at the
table um what's called an open table
meaning if you're here today and you
want to connect with the risen jesus
then you're welcome to um to participate
so i'm going to walk you through um
taking of the bread and the cup i'm
going to do it by reading again that
passage from
paul
where he kind of unpacks what all this
or what this all means so he says this
for i received from the lord what i also
passed on to you
the lord jesus on the night he was
betrayed he took the bread and when he
given thanks he broke it and he said
this is my body which is for you do this
in remembrance of me
go ahead and partake of your bread
in the same way
after supper he took the cup saying this
cup is the new covenant
in my blood
do this whenever you drink it in
remembrance of me
go ahead and take up your cup
for whenever you eat this bread
and drink this cup
you proclaim the lord's death
until he comes
that's how you take communion rightly
amen
[Music]
come all shapes
your broken
[Music]
oh
from near and far
[Music]
this room
joining
[Music]
come
come to jesus
[Music]
come and stay
come to the table
[Music]
come eat and drink
recline at the table
[Music]
just come as you are
come next
[Music]
[Applause]
we're ready to
feel
is
[Music]
as a kingdom
well thank you
thank you for being here tonight um
just for
learning to be the church together it's
a it's a good thing beautiful path we're
on so just a reminder that uh the sign
up for the trunk retreat is right there
at the back a little little table right
there and you can just sign up with your
name and email and we'll get you more
information
i mean it's honestly it's pretty simple
basically you buy a bag of candy
decorate your trunk however you'd like
and then give the children candy um i
mean you know they're not gonna analyze
your trunk like well
they didn't really do this up very good
i mean just you know have candy they'll
be happy so don't be intimidated let's
join you guys hey the more cars we have
out there the better it's gonna be fun
for all the kids so uh you can sign up
there um
also
if let's see they're gonna have any
visitors we're good there
if you'd like to give if you consider
the table your church home and you'd
like to give there's a small box in the
back there in the hallway that you can
give or
you can go online of course on our
website and donate that way so if you
resonate with who we are and the vision
god's called us to then we welcome you
to do that so
all right i'm gonna send you out with
this um
this blessing this benediction
you are god's servants
you're gifted with dreams
you're gifted with visions
and upon you rest the grace of god like
flames of living fire
go
love
serve the lord
in the strength
of the holy spirit
god bless you
go in peace
you're dismissed
hey